I have say when you got it on it looks
quite simple it is obviously blue and
black it is totally blue and black were
you surprised to see this outrage if you
like that it's caused on Twitter yeah it
has been a major surprise for all of us
here at Roman originals we were not
expecting when we wake up this morning
to have this media cover and all these
buzz and everything that has been going
on so yes we've been very busy in sales
we've been busy with the prayers it has
been a such exciting day have you seen
people actually coming to buy the dress
now that it's got this miraculous if you
like kind of publicity yes everyone once
bit the one the blue and black but also
their controversy with a white and well
this is no gold but we have the white
and black so everyone is asking for them
where did you first find out about it
I'd love to know the moment when you
realize that this media storm if you
like had been caused well apparently the
guys that manage the website they were
open about about four o'clock in the
morning they made it here to head office
about five and since then he hasn't
stopped because we start applying the
tweet the internet got very very busy
very rapidly and it's just been an
honest up day I mean right now it's
nearly eight o'clock and we keep going
the internet is still taking orders
everything is happening